if you had a any kind of industry in
America that failed as baldly and naked
Lee and obviously as American higher
education has if any other industry like
that performed that way it would
collapse so I've seen what keeps it
going and of course the answer is people
like me
I am Nicholas be four recent TV and
today I'm talking to Andrew Ferguson
author of crazy you one dad's crash
course in getting his son into college
and Gilliam Ferguson the actual son so
Andy Gilliam thanks for coming thank you
Andy this is crash course about going to
college your son is now a sophomore at
University of Virginia what struck you
is the biggest change since you applied
for college the money because everything
seems to turn on money you mentioned I
spent some time with this College
private college counselor who charges 40
thousand dollars in a sort of soup to
nuts thing and getting your kid from
freshman year in high school into the
school of his or her choice over four
years and there were parents willing to
pay it that's what I couldn't believe on
top of that then the schools and cells
are so rich you went to Occidental
College during what in the mid-70 okay
so Occidental College which is most
famous for President Obama leaving there
for a better school did you take going
to college that seriously no I thought
was I grew up in Chicago and I thought
how what's the farthest away I can get
from Chicago and remain in the
contiguous United States and then I
heard a Beach Boys song and it was I was
a goner gal him when did you start
thinking about College seriously I'm
about two weeks before the applications
were due he's not leading that line of
course my father was planning all these
trips and you know bugging me about my
essays I couldn't walk to the bathroom
without asked if I'd started of course I
had him if you want to know what he was
like during the process imagine that
last scene in Titanic with those bodies
lying face-down that that was my boy
right and like pointing what's function
of college for parents well prestige
status in fact you know it is the
parents are the linchpin of this thing
you know I think about it the other day
if if you had a in any kind of industry
in America that failed as baldly and
naked
and obviously as American higher
education has in which would cost too
much money kids don't learn anything
kids don't graduate I mean it's like six
year graduation rites of most good
schools are built a durable and the
people have to go heavily into debt to
get through it if any other industry
like that performed that way it would
collapse i mean we're seeing it in the
American Automobile Industry so I've
seen what keeps it going and of course
the answer is people like me people who
are willing to put up with all this
insanity totally all rationality to it
and pay whatever they have to college
really only became a mass phenomenon in
the in the 70s right so is it that we
have professionalized parents as well as
professionalized students yes well the
professionalization of childhood I mean
it's not my discovery but they have
things now that this is all stuff that
absolutely new and that he was immune
from mostly which is they had things
called brag sheets which parents start
compiling when the kids are in seventh
and eighth grade and it's you know they
put together you know they compiled
videos of their athletic performances
capture their musical recitals and they
put them all together so the kids got a
resume in fact sometimes they even call
it a resume what do you hope to get out
of college mainly just a group of people
that I can call my friends for the rest
of my life that I'll be close to
obviously the education I guess to what
my well my dad would say but then you
know if it wouldn't if that can put me
in a good position to get a job and a
good family in the future then I think
that's all that I would you sound like a
girl going to college in the 50s you're
looking for an mr degree huh family and
friends all my my objective is to be a
stay-at-home dad yeah ok well I think
that a lot of that's opening up the
connection between where you get a
college and where you end up in life is
a lot looser than more generally LEDs
there's almost no correlation actually I
mean it's it's been studied you know out
your ear about their professional
happiness income level divorce rates
family togetherness and break up all of
that
it has no relationship to where you went
to school I guess in in income levels it
might at the very top of schools Ivy
Leaguers I think tend to make more money
but but beyond that in the great mass of
schools it's it's your material so what
do you hope he gets out of it a lot of
debt burdened with debt so it'll build
his character as he goes through life
and well you know I want a slow
nurturing of the Spirit and I'm not and
now i'm not being i mean i want him to
and we talked about this quite often I'm
sort of like Matthew Arnold dev okay I
mean I want him to familiarize himself
with the best that's been thought and
said and understand Western civilization
in the roots of it and where it comes
from and that ain't going to happen and
what happened to it yeah what happened
to it a final question a Gilliam will
you will you debase and humiliate your
children by writing a book about their
college hunt experience or will you come
up with a completely new way to debase a
human later I don't know everything I
don't think I could come up with a new
way because he's done just about all of
them Andy what uh what's your next
project you've got other kids right so
what you've got other kids are you oh
yeah well minus my major product in life
my daughter is is going through the
process right now we're in that terrible
limbo where she's got the applications
in but we're waiting to hear from it you
know they have to tell you by April
first so it's kind of I'm nervous again
well Gilliam Ferguson Andrew Ferguson
author of crazy you one dad's finished
the subtitle for me whining dad's crash
course in on getting his kid into
college I think I got the preposition
right it's out now it's doing well
thanks very much for talking with thanks
a lot nick i'm nick gillespie